[Music]
once a destination for family fun
britain's seaside towns used to be
places to celebrate childhood
now children from London come here for
very different reasons swept up in an
undercurrent of crime
vulnerable young people are being
targeted by gangs and traffic to areas
around the country to sell Class A drugs
on the streets this is known as running
county lines it's the business one of
the dealers we spoke to knows well for
years he recruited children or workers
as he calls them from London and took
them to the countryside it's a dangerous
and illegal world and we've protected
the identities of the people we spoke to
the workers they range from white black
fat skinny young old whoever wants to
work they just out there they only just
stay there trying to get their attention
my dear little things they want to be
known they want to be able to beat guys
you kind of notice them as well and they
just like when you think yet you just
approach say what you can walk on she he
goes yeah
okay cool you start probably wearing for
real at ten workers at least some of
them mess up some of them get arrested
some just car handle pressure glass at
them so some just go through them like
water you might just think yeah I'm
gonna poke it off the money starts
messing up all see it's punishment in it
and he can get killed for that can do
he's messing with someone's business in
it so it's not a game as this saying it
can you describe the demographic of the
young people that you would recruit to
work in the countryside I would say from
a broken home I would say from poverty
and lacking son he needs that male
figure in his life I think he wants to
be a part of son we've heard of children
as young as twelve being pressured or
coerced into selling drugs this way
Chris was 16 when he was trafficked all
over southern England a soul class a
crack Aaron in the city as well we gun
stout there even a crack at a soar B&B
I didn't like it crackheads can't be
quite violent sometimes you know you've
got money and they want to rob you for
it I've got friends who've been cut on
their faces I've got friends who've been
hit with needles you know so yeah they
can be quite violent when they want to
come so there's the potential of that or
being apprehended and charged with the
intent supplier which can face a lot of
years in prisons for that you know Chris
told me even young people who are
seemingly willing have little real
choice maybe Devon got the same footing
in their estate and it kind of been
exploited because it don't really have a
choice if they want things to run
smoother for them in their community
then it's better they go and do this
because it might give them some immunity
in a recent series of dawn raids across
England the police intercepted a
criminal network suspected of
trafficking young boys and girls from
southeast London to Hampshire and Kent
there's growing concern at the
vulnerability of young people traffic
this way we had a group of very really
young children
he was sleeping on beaches and they were
they would they would stop being sent to
the countryside together and they would
essentially been failed by the look they
were known to the local authority they
had suffered extreme former in in their
in their homes and the local authority
were in care homes and they were
responding and it's very similar to the
kinds of kids that we're seeing in the
watch Dell and Oxford cases where there
in these care homes and actually the
provisions aren't looking after them and
not safeguarding them and so you get to
get the girls that are being sexually
exploited the Home Secretary says she
acknowledges the problem I think what
has surprised people is that this is
also a business that is undertaken by
organised criminals in the UK itself so
there will be people be people adults
and other and younger people being moved
from different parts of the UK elsewhere
within the country into exploitation
into affectively modern slavery with
deep deprivation and long-term economic
decline Clacton is just the kind of
place traffic as a targeting demand for
drugs is high and competition is scarce
for local users trying to break the
habit outsiders have changed the face of
the drug scene you're trying so hard but
yeah it's pressed in front of your face
and no one's doing nothing about it you
know especially if you want to get clean
it's like they're in the middle of town
so you can't even go and do your
shopping without seeing saying please
sublime two people dealing drugs but are
so quick to pull you over and give you a
search like you're just walking down the
road you know what I mean they are
London people people coming down from
London what kind of age 15 year-olds
onwards I've seen 16 year-olds doing
deals like a pair of 16 year old boys
who couldn't even buy themselves some
filters so there are more aggressive in
the way that they talk they treat you
like absolute talk down to you as well
so the whole aggression with everything
and weapons yeah they're always carrying
knives on them guns drug addiction is
already embedded in small towns like
klaxon but the influx of city dealers is
inflaming the problem we see the effects
of what the new dailies are because we
see new people coming into treatment
this year was in the increasing 10% in
people coming through our system
heroin particularly I looked at the
stats yesterday that the we've got a 10%
increase in heroin for opiate use
cocaine uses is fairly steady cannabis
use particularly in young people as well
as only increase legal highs they're
increasing but not particularly in this
area but staying a step ahead is a
challenge for the police
the gangs involved in trafficking bring
sophisticated tactics for avoiding
detection and heightened levels of
violence there has been some indications
that perhaps people from outside the
tendrán area perhaps find it easier or
more used to use higher levels of force
to conduct their their criminal
activities and also perhaps there's been
some more sophisticated concealment of
drugs and I recently we found some
certain packages of Class A drugs hidden
very well behind the dashboards of cars
for example and that's not the levels of
sophistication that we've seen here
locally before there's overlapping
criminality in places like this with
powerful gangs and drug addicts all part
of an almost impenetrable underworld but
increasingly it's clear that some of the
most vulnerable children are deeply
involved too without any real choice F
or Hirsch Sky News
you